[موسيقى]
من حين اللي اخر كان هذا الامر يثير جدلا
كبيرا في مصر نقاش قديمه
واطباء حول التبرع بالاعضاء بعد الوفاه
واحقيه الشخص في التصرف بجسده وصاحب ذلك
وما زالت موجات من الرفض الدينيه اصطدمت
برياح من الرغبه الطبيه
واجهضت حلما كان قرب المنال لالاف المرضى
احنا كل يوم بيموت اطفال وشباب وناس عايشه
على غسيل الكلى ثلاث مرات في الاسبوع
عايشه معاناه يعني اي حد بيتالم عنده قلب
عنده كلى عنده كبد مش هو بس اللي بيعاني
هو وعيلته وبيته وكله ماديا ومعنويا
ونفسيا 20% من الناس وهي على قائمه
الانتظار بتموت او بتخرج بره القائمه ليه
لان تدهورك حالتهم نتيجه طول الانتظار فما
يستحملش عمليه كبيره فيموت هيخرج مش هيزرع
خلاص احنا وصلنا لمرحله اا اخيره للزرع
فلازم همم نتحرك بسرعه جدا وهمم الوقت مش
في صالحنا لان الولد حالته متاخره وهمم
ولازم الزرع بسرعه
ورغم اقرار الحكومه المصريه قانونا يسمح
بنقل وزراعه الاعضاء من خلال التبرع الا
ان القانونه ضل غير مفعل ولا يعول عليه
كثيرا حتى فقد الكثير الامل في تنفيذه
وانقاذ حياه المرضى ممن يحتاجون للزراعه
انا لو انا حصل لي انه انا ما لقيتش عضو
حلو مين ما اقدرش اقول لهم الحكومه انا
اللي لازم اقوله هو المجتمع انه ما فيش حد
قابليه يفكر لو انا احتاجت